cannes sa croisette ses plages et son
palais des festivals d'ailleurs est-ce
que vous êtes déjà rentrés dedans allez
je vous y emmène
[Musique]
suite
on se retrouve dans la salle de la
conférence de presse du festival de
cannes le film coupé réalisé par michel
hazanavicius sera présenté aujourd'hui
les acteurs le réalisateur aussi seront
présents pour parler du film aux
journalistes ici ça va commencer dans
quelques minutes venir ici ouvrir un
festival avec un film un film joyeux
ccc à la fois étrange et un grand
honneur alors qu'une centaine de
journalistes présents ils sont espagnols
américains ou encore japonais et
viennent poser leurs questions à
l'équipe du film et moi aussi je vais me
lancer comment est-ce qu'on choisit un
tel lieu de tournage qu'elle et yale et
les contraintes que vous aviez on allait
à bondoufle
quelle ville
aïe enfin bon c'est à 50 km de paris on
est dans un hippodrome
abandonné dans lequel il ya des
chevreuils des sangliers moi je
cherchais un lieu dont d'abord qui
esthétiquement colle aux films et
et qui en plus est une espèce de
topologie qui me permettait d'avoir les
courses des trucs et machins de 2,2
voilà tout ce dont j'avais besoin et en
plus il est très pop ce ce lieu donc
j'ai ça a été vraiment énorme coup de
bol tu m'avais j'ai un coup de bol pour
ce tournage l'histoire d'un film de
zombies dans un film et pour le
spectateur de vision d'un même récit
jeanne estimé qu'au début on voit
quelque chose on est forcément mis en
tant que spectateur dans une situation
de critique et de jugement on juge quoi
on se dit c'est de la daube je suis en
train de regarder un navet intersidéral
et puis l'histoire se raconte autrement
on change de point de vue de
perspectives et tout d'un coup on est
critique par rapport à son propre
jugement et en fait on fait une
expérience de bienveillance et sa jeune
et beaucoup ça
et maintenant il ne vous reste plus qu'à
aller voir le film dans les salles de
cinéma